So, we've been looking at lots of different plots of the same data, and talking
about some of the trade-offs that are involved
in data visualization. So, which plot should you
choose? One important answer is that you
don't have to choose. In exploratory data analysis,
we'll often create multiple visualizations and summaries of
the same data, gleaning different incites from each.
So, through out the course, as we iteratively
refine a particular plot of the same data, it's
not that the later versions are always better
than the previous versions. Sometimes they are. But, sometimes
they're just revealing different things about the same
data. Now, when it comes time to share your
work with a larger audience, you may need
to choose one or two visualizations that best communicate,
the main findings of your work.